it is teacher appreciation week which
is you know pretty much should be every
week especially in this last year
absolutely um we really put our sweet
incredible innovative dedicated and
patient teachers through the ringer this
year and
actor in front of the show max
greenfield he posted this
beautiful photo of his little one and if
that doesn't sum it up nothing does
that's max's son ozzy and the caption is
hashtag
teacher appreciation weeks thanks mrs
patricia
for the past year max has been hilarious
posting pics of his kids home school
journey on
instagram he just looks like such a good
dad
does this sum up what it felt like for
you with your kids
no this is way too sweet
i uh there were no images for
what it was like in my house yeah um
yeah
fire flames like cats
[Music]
so it was fun and thanks to all the
teachers and thanks max for posting that
pic because l-o-l all right next we got
some huge
green news from the happiest place on
earth it got a little happier
people reports that disney parks are
going solar
sound goofy well listen
to these stats in orlando within the
next two years solar facilities will
power
40 percent of walt disney world and in
anaheim disneyland has already installed
1400 solar panels and over in france
disneyland paris they've built
huge solar canopies to generate power
while shading 9 500 cars in the parking
lot
and they say all their global efforts
together could power
eight magic kingdoms my question is
how much sun power does it make to spin
a tea cup and make those churros
that uh i zone in on whenever i go to
disneyland
i loves me at sure but i love
that the solar panels are in the shape
of the mouse
yeah cute whoever thought of that idea
just chef's kiss
and thank you disneyland in general once
again
for showing the power of a corporate
example of how we need to proceed into
our future so that we may have one
absolutely so thank you disney thank you
thank you thank you
we also have some news for the hopeful
singles out there i was actually talking
about this with vanessa hudgins
earlier um and how she was saying dating
apps is kind of
so photo first and that's not everyone's
approach it's definitely not mine
and tinder has got this brand new
feature i'm so excited about it
mashable reports that vibe
is an app feature designed to help users
get better
matches so it quizzes you on different
types of pop culture and personality
questions
to get a better feel for how you vibe
and match up to others for example
here's one are you a 20 minutes early
or a 10 minutes late kind of person i
would have to put 20 minutes early
because you know
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh
i'm working on it i'm working on it it's
gotten so much better this year can you
imagine how bad it used to be
i'm working on it this is great because
like you it's a way to sort of get to
know
somebody like you said more than just
like not you know
a picture in a swipe right you know for
some people
like a 10 minutes late kind of person
could be such a deal breaker for a
20-minute early type
of person totally um that being said i
do wonder
and we talked about this like do they
also think that opposites can attract
like if you're into sports and
you're into the arts that's great like
you can do museums and
baseball games like so i'm just curious
about all of it but i'm
so excited about these little features
that give
just more insight than a darn photo
because that's how people are me that
you have to be on the apps if you're
going to meet people now especially
during quarantine during all of this
time that's how it's working and you've
got to know things like are you okay
with letting your dog kiss your face
like that's something you want to know
or would you rather watch a true crime
documentary or 90 day fiance the answer
to that question
even though there is some true crime in
90 day fiance if you watch but
the answer to that question is vital
you got to know i won't dislike you if
you're into something i'm not you could
expand my horizons and vice versa
all right hey but how about this finally
it's the news that makes our
tongues go tingling it's the food news
all right and today we have a food
challenge of epic
proportions well three feet to be exact
it's the fruit roll-up challenge
distractify reports this food feat is
heating up on tick tock
everyone's doing it the rules are simple
you know those fruit by the foot
well we have those we're going to
unravel them right here and then you put
one end in your mouth and without using
our hands
we see who can gobble it down fastest
and drew and i are gonna do this right
now look here we have it
i don't know what the best uh strategy
is i don't know i've never done this
okay but we need you all to root us on
okay
all right ready fat fruit
oh look it's so hard
[Applause]
really oh it was harder than it looks